bien comme vous vous en souvenez tout a
commencé le dimanche 24
le prétexte c'était le général massu
relevé de son commandement des tracts
avaient convié toute la population
algéroise à manifester dans les rues
or lorsque les algérois manifestent dans
la rue ils se rendent généralement sur
le forum en face du gouvernement général
c'est pourquoi des dispositifs spéciaux
avaient été pris à cet endroit et la
foule devait rouler vers le plateau des
glières
il faisait très beau à alger les
algérois n'avait pas grand chose à faire
en ce dimanche après midi
aussi était-il très nombreux et ses
quelques minutes après ces images que le
drame devait éclater la fièvre montait
au fur et à mesure des yeux que les
heures passaient ont commencé à arracher
des panneaux on commençait déjà à
préparer les barricades dans le centre
d'alger du côté de la rue michelet
la circulation était complètement arrêté
et ce fut la fusillade à 18 heures nous
n'avons pas d'image de cette fusillade
pour la simple raison qu'elle s'est
produite au moment où il faisait nuit
pendant peut-être un jour ou deux jours
on a hésité pour savoir où était
exactement les responsabilités de cette
fusillade
maintenant c'est certain c'est formel ce
sont les manifestants qui ont ouvert le
feu les premiers
on peut même précisé que le feu était
ouvert par deux fusils mitrailleurs l'un
qui se trouvait au premier étage de ce
qui devait être plus tard le pc de
monsieur ortis l'autre se trouvant sur
un toit de l'autre côté de la rue il
paraîtrait même je ne peux pas vous
confirmer cette information que l'un des
deux tireurs est actuellement entre les
mains de la justice
et c'est le lendemain que commencer la
semaine dans la lch
dès le lendemain la foule revenait en
masse du côté du plateau des glières et
immédiatement se dressaient les
premières barricades
c'était généralement des jeunes gens qui
venaient du quartier de bab el-oued
c'est à dire du quartier de monsieur
artis qui travaillait activement à la
construction de ces barricades ont
retiré les pavés comme on pouvait on
faisait la chaîne et petit à petit ces
barricades montées donnant à alger un
aspect deux places fortes
ou presque
et quelques heures plus tard ces
barricades avaient plus d'un mètre
cinquante de hauteur c'était la grève
générale qui avait été décrété tous les
rideaux de fer étaient baissées le
commerce était complètement arrêtées à
alger il était impossible de trouver un
restaurant ouvert il était impossible
d'acheter un paquet de cigarettes
il était impossible d'acheter quoi que
ce soit la vie c'était complètement
arrêtée et les algérois n'avez rien
d'autre à faire que de venir au plateau
des glières pour voir ce qui s'y passait
les trains ne roulait plus les cheminots
se joignait au mouvement de grève
générale et voilà cette fameuse place
des glières avec dans le fond la
barricade de la rue charles péguy qui
devait être le centre d'attraction de
toute la population algéroise pendant
plusieurs jours néanmoins dans les
environs d'alger
on voyait arriver les premiers renforts
de troupes le dispositif commencé à se
mettre en place
les troupes devaient abandonner souvent
des zones opérationnelles où elle aurait
été évidemment beaucoup plus utile et la
population venait en curieux comme ces
images vous le prouvent ces
manifestations avaient quand même un peu
l'aspect d'une grande kermesse
d'un côté les insurgés de l'autre côté
les algérois au balcon monsieur ortis
qui avait déjà fait installer ami trop
et qui lançait ses slogans par
l'intermédiaire de ses haut parleurs sur
les barricades des algérois qui la
plupart étaient des territoriaux les
slogans commencer à s'inscrire sur les
banderoles
et au pc de monsieur orleans parvenait
se faire inscrire au nom venait demander
des laissez-passer quant au chef rebelle
ortis il était très calme à son duo
ortiz se promener dans les rues personne
ne l'inquiétait les barricades se
consolider la gaillarde rendez visite à
ortiz de temps en temps retourner à son
pc qui étaient postés dans les facultés
mais la gaillarde n'aimait pas les
atteindre
puis on apprenait que de l'aérodrome
d'alger décoller un avion ayant à son
bord les parlementaires vals gr
on reconnaît monsieur kawa qui
aujourd'hui a été arrêté à son retour à
orly comme viens de vous le dire léon
zitrone les parlementaires venaient à
paris pour expliquer ce qu'était la
situation d'alger expliquer à leur
manière
[Musique]
par contre dans la casbah l'animation
était normal les musulmans se
désintéresser de cette affaire qui ne
concernait que les français d'alger à
plusieurs reprises on devait faire
pression sur les musulmans mais sans
succès et jeudi c'est elle obsèques des
victimes
les gendarmes avec beaucoup de dignité
et sans la moindre manifestation de la
part de la population algéroise
non
et la situation restait inchangée les
insurgés se rendant compte qu'il était
absolument nécessaire pour eux
d'associer les musulmans à leur
manifestation faisait des efforts
désespérés pour que les musulmans quitte
la casbah malgré un grand renfort de
propagande
il arrivait seulement à trouver si l'on
peut dire une trentaine de figurants qui
acceptait de venir aux barricades du
côté de la rue d'isly
cette participation musulmane qui
n'avaient évidemment aucun rapport avec
celle qu'on avait connue au 13 mai et
est immédiatement monté en épingle par
les meneurs qui prétendait que les
musulmans étaient avec ce qu'était un
ensemble
les élèves d'alger à laives naissent
dépenses et essayer de faire la navette
entre la mairie et les insurgés déposé
des couronnes et donner l'impression
d'être en plein accord avec les insulter
[Musique]
aux balcons ortis continué à lancer ses
slogans et continuer à intoxiquer la
population algéroise avec sa propagande
[Musique]
on lisait les nouvelles n'étaient pas
toujours très objective l'hôtel de ville
étaient occupées par les forces
territoriales le ravitaillement arrivait
régulièrement dans le fortin des
insurgés personne ne s'y opposer
[Musique]
tout alger était dans l'expectative
qu'allait-il se passer comment allait-on
en sortir
[Musique]
puis ce fut la journée de vendredi on
savait que le général de gaulle devait
parler et tout le monde était à son
poste de radio ou de télévision les
librement de leur destin quand d'une
manière ou d'une autre conclusion d'un
cessez le feu ou écrasement total des
rebelles nous aurons mis un terme au
combat
et quand après une période prolongée
d'apaisement les populations auront pu
prendre conscience de l'enjeu et
accomplir grâce à nous certains progrès
politiques économiques sociaux colère et
cetera alors les algériens diront ce
qu'ils veulent être cela ne leur sera
pas dictée aucun soldat à aucun moment
et même passivement ne doit s'associer à
la rébellion
en fin de compte
l'ordre public devra être en rétabli oui
il peut y avoir des moyens de diverses
sortes pour que force reste à la loi
mais vous devez y parvenir c'est l'ordre
que j'ai donné et c'est l'ordre que je
donne
c'est l'ordre que j'ai donné c'est
l'ordre que je donne le général de
gaulle avait parlé et on sentait
immédiatement à alger que quelque chose
avait changé
le dispositif était renforcé le plateau
des glières et le monument aux morts
était toujours dégager les forces de
l'ordre commençaient à mettre les
camions et la foule n'avait plus qu'à
que c'est difficilement au plateau des
glières qui avait été son lieu de
rassemblement de pin's néanmoins barrage
était forcé non dimanche au cours de la
journée du dimanche après-midi et la
foule entre est encore en contact avec
les insurgés aux barricades
c'était la dernière fois
[Musique]
on
des barbelés faisait leur apparition
à
reporter sentais qu'il y avait quelque
chose dans l'air en effet lundi matin on
voyait sortir du réduit en colonnes par
un des insurgés qui étaient restés
jusqu'au bout et qui avait accepté de se
rendre souvent certaines conditions qui
leur avait été imposé par le colonel
dufour insurrection d'alger était
terminée elle se termine et heureusement
sans effusion de sang
mais croyez-moi ce qu'ils étaient âgés
ont eu peur ont même eu très peur
pendant plusieurs jours que les choses
se passent beaucoup plus bas
ils étaient environ 400 à monter dans
les camions pour se rendre au pc du
premier acte
camions bâchés la traversée de la ville
de vesper sans incident la population ne
manifestant plus comprenant que cette
insurrection avait échoué
lagarde qui était resté le dernier sur
la place des glières se retrouve
maintenant comme vous le savez déjà à la
santé telles sont donc les faits jax
albert mais il reste à nous donner à
donner aux téléspectateurs vos
impressions personnelles de témoins eh
bien je dirais que mes impressions
elles sont encore assez confuse je ne
suis rentré d'algérie il y à quelques
heures évidemment ce qui intéresse le
plus les témoins de ces dernières
journées ce sont les responsabilités
on aimerait que soit établi les
responsabilités monsieur michel devrait
y vient de dire tout à l'heure à la
tribune que la justice était saisie
ce n'est donc pas à moi d'aborder ce
problème c'est un problème
gouvernementale je n'ai pas les dossiers
je ne donnerai donc aucune opinion sur
les responsabilités de ces journées
d'alger mais comment at on pu en arriver
là il faut comprendre qu'entre âgées
paris il y à un divorce de penser en
quelque sorte des français de la
métropole et les français d'algérie ne
sont pas sur la même longueur d'onde
il y à alger une ignorance totale de ce
que pense la métropole et j'irai même
plus loin il y a un certain mépris de la
part des algérois pour ce que pensent
les métropolitains on ne sait pas
pourquoi mais les algérois tout au moins
certains d'entre eux ont le sentiment
réellement qu'il gouverne la france
ils vous diront que ce sont eux qui ont
libéré la france après l'occupation
fait le 13 mai et qui ont amené la vème
république
ils ont fait simplement une erreur de
calcul cette fois ci ils n'ont pas
compté avec l'opinion de la métropole il
croyait que le 13 mai s'était fait
uniquement parce que il avait poussé des
cris sur le forum parce qu'ils avaient
pris d'assaut le gouvernement général il
n'avait pas réalisé que le 13 mai avait
été possible parce que la métropole elle
aussi était fatigué de la quatrième
république
cette fois ci donc ils ont cru qu'en
refaisant un mouvement de masse qu en
s'enfermant à l'intérieur d'un fortin
tout cela était suffisant pour qu'une
fois de plus le gouvernement change sa
politique même que le gouvernement
change d'homme ou même que le
gouvernement change ses institutions et
il n'était absolument pas averti de ce
qu'on pouvait penser les français de la
métropole
mais comment peut-il ignorer à ce point
l'opinion et bien il faut comprendre que
tout de même les algérois les algériens
voient ce problème sous un angle
passionnel nous sommes sur les bords de
la méditerranée n'oubliez pas et en plus
tout de même ces gens vivent dans le
pays
ils sont évidemment en contact direct
tous les jours avec le problème algérien
et ils sont en plus
intoxiqué par une certaine presse que
vous préfère ne pas qualifier et par
certains slogans et ils ne croient que
leur meneur je vais vous citer un
exemple personnel parce que j'étais à
alger je fais apostrophé sur le trottoir
par des algérois me disant naturellement
radio alger encore menti vous êtes en
train de nous raconter que tout est fini
à oran et constantine alors ce n'est pas
vrai j'ai je regrette mais d'après
toutes les informations nous avons en
effet tout est fini à oran et
constantine et alors vous ne venez pas
l'entendre que vient de dire ortis
comprenez ce que disait ortis à son
micro et à son balcon
c'était parole d'évangile c'était la
vérité ce que disaient les autres ce que
pouvait dire le gouvernement se nourrit
des agences de presse que pour les
journalistes
tout ça ça ne comptait pas seul comptait
ce que disaient les meneurs et et pour
eux voyez-vous il n'existe qu'un seul
problème en réalité il n'existe que le
problème algérien
si vous essayez de ré expliquer que le
problème algérien doit être étudié dans
le contexte de tous les problèmes de la
france c'est à dire le problème
économique des problèmes de politique
étrangère problèmes de la communauté
alors à ce moment-là ils vous regardent
avec un sourire méprisant en pensant
encore un imbécile qui n'a rien compris
à la question algérienne
ils ne réfléchissent pas ils n'essayent
pas de comprendre ils sont mal renseigné
et voilà à quoi on y arrive quel serait
votre conclusion
il ya ma conclusion c'est que des
algérois actuellement sont intoxiqués
ils sont intoxiqués ils sont ignorants
ils n'essayent pas de réfléchir il
n'hésite pas de comprendre les problèmes
il réagi sur le plan passionnel il y a
un énorme travail à faire pour leur
apprendre exactement ce que pense la
france et pour leur apprendre exactement
ce que sont les problèmes de la vie
merci beaucoup
[Musique]